Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Finally, OpenAI’s legendary language model
AI, GPT-4 which also now powers their ChatGPT
assistant, is here.
And my goodness, they promise a lot of goodies.
Advanced reasoning.
Complex instructions.
More creativity.
This is going to be an incredible journey,
so hold on to your papers right now, Fellow
Scholars.
And, get this, it can also accept image inputs.
Let’s put this one to work immediately.
Dear GPT-4, imagine that we have these ingredients.
What can we make from them?
Note that the input is not a text anymore,
but a photo.
That is excellent, and don’t forget, if
one of these caught your eye, you can also
ask follow up questions here on how to exactly
make them.
Now, earlier we looked at some preliminary
results of an IQ-test, where it scored 147.
However, I noted immediately that we should
be good Fellow Scholars and take this with
a little bit of skepticism, and wait for a
more formal examination.
And, yes - here it is!
It finally happened.
GPT-4 give us human-level performance on a
variety of academic benchmarks.
And they report something absolutely incredible.
Look.
This is what its previous incarnation in ChatGPT
was capable of doing.
10th percentile on the bar exam.
And now, maybe 30?
50?
Nope, 90th percentile.
This means that the new one is within the
top 10 percent of test takers.
That kind of improvement in just one paper
is outstanding.
And, I know you are looking, and the answer
is of course, we are going to talk about this
too in a moment.
And this is where being able to process visual
information means an incredible breakthrough.
It doesn’t just mean that it can help us
with the ingredients, or can explain memes.
Although that is quite helpful.
But, it gets better.
For instance, look at this one.
Yummy.
On the AMC mathematical exam, GPT-4 marked
with light green performs so much better than
the previous version.
However, here is where the magic happens.
Look, this exam contains some light visual
information, and when we add the capability
to process this to GPT-4, it does so much
better.
It is rapidly improving to match human-level
results.
We are one step closer to human-level intelligence.
This work is history in the making.
And, I was also very excited about this.
The USA Biology Olympiad exam.
This needs next-level capabilities, because
it requires visually inspecting and evaluating
electrocardiograms, and in general, taking
in a ton of visual information and giving
correct answers.
So how correct was it?
What?
Are you kidding?
99th percentile.
Better than almost all humans.
Wow.
However, wait a minute.
I see light green, not dark green.
What does that mean?
I mean that is the non-vision version of GPT-4.
But this exam has plenty of images.
So, what happened?
Well, the AI got a little help.
The images have been transcribed by a human.
I would love to see those transcriptions,
I bet it was not an easy job.
So, it seemingly cannot perform this level
of visual inspection yet, but I am certain
that we will see something like this one or
two more papers down the line.
Perhaps with GPT-5.
If that sounds interesting, consider subscribing
and hitting the bell icon to not miss it when
the next paper drops.
Here is also an example that I absolutely
loved.
Little AI, explain the plot of Cinderella
and each word has to begin with the next letter
in the alphabet from A to Z.
Wow.
This one is tough.
I have to admit, I am not sure if most people
would be able to solve this in a satisfactory
manner.
And…look at that.
Flying colors.
My goodness.
And this is one more really cool example from
their official demo.
What?
Are you saying that this crude drawing for
a website comes in, with some jokes and buttons.
And it not only creates this website with
proper javascript, but it also understands
that it needs to fill in the jokes, and it
does that too.
Loving it.
So, when can we try it?
Well, OpenAI deployed GPT-4 to their ChatGPT
Plus subscribers, and they also made a waitlist
for API access.
Now, I was lucky enough to have access to
it, thank you so much, and it already helped
me remember my discussion with a geologist
professor from a few years ago.
There were some details I did not remember,
and now I do.
Thank you!
So, who is using it?
The answer is that everyone is using it.
It can help us organize a huge knowledge base,
or it can help us learn a new language, and
so much more.
And this is tech transfer, so in other words,
from paper to product, not in decades, but
in a matter of days, and in some cases, even
a matter of hours.
What a time to be alive!
And if you have been watching Two Minute Papers,
you see the whole history of these works,
from GPT-2, to GPT-3 and now, GPT-4.
You saw history unfold right before your eyes.
Thank you so much for being on this incredible
journey with me.
Now, I will also note that the paper is really
detailed in terms of the evaluation of the
results, but a little light on the inner workings
of the algorithm itself.
I hope we get to know more soon.
Thanks for watching and
for your generous support, and I'll see
you next time!